jephté vous avez inauguré une nouvelle
ligne aérienne pour le japon exactement
oui la ligne transpolaires d'air france
qui emmène 30 heures nous conduite de
paris à tokyo vient corriger le premier
contact avec le japon est évidemment les
drones de tokyo haneda où nous sommes
actuellement très bon directeur de vols
ça représente par rapport à la route du
sud par karachi bangkok cei dont il
manie ça représente un gain de 15 heures
va pas se trouve classique messieurs
maxime ans je crois oui monsieur maximum
ce président directeur général d'air
france a fait le voyage avec vous oui un
compagnie de monsieur monnerville que
voici avec l'ambassadeur de france
monsieur armand bérard nous allons
d'ailleurs nous rendre le tout de suite
l'ambassade de france l'aérodrome est
très moderne
oui l'aérodrome est très moderne il est
situé à la périphérie de tokyo mais
pratiquement il n'y a pas de solution de
continuité entre l'aérodrome et la ville
puisque la ville est très étendue et
nouveau sirh l'ambassade de france qui
situé sur une colline dans la périphérie
de tokyo
ici c'est la résidence de l'ambassadeur
dit situé au sommet de cette colline des
bureaux et en os au pied s'ils voulaient
résidence qui est entourée d'un parc
c'était la saison des cerisiers s'était
même déjà un petit peu avancé la bonne
saison pour les cerisiers c
le début de la fin mars la fin mars nous
étions à ce moment là vers le milieu
d'avril et c'était bien peu avancé nous
avons vu des signes en fleurs mais à une
certaine altitude
ici c'est la résidence de l'ambassadeur
une résidence que n'a pas connue
évidemment paul claudel qui fut comme
vous le savez bon nombre d'années
ambassadeur de france au japon
ici un lurçat tout est très clair très
aéré ah oui absolument malgré le temps
qui n'était pas pas exceptionnel à ce
moment là et nous assistons actuellement
à la 2e des réceptions qui avait été
donnée par l'ambassadeur la première
réussite le jour de l'arrivée celle ci
était quelques jours plus tard et il y
était convié le président le président
du conseil japonais et les membres du
gouvernement japonais
c'est une réception qui n'a pas duré
très longtemps d'ailleurs parce que les
membres du gouvernement japonais est aux
prises avec des problèmes assez
difficiles qui ont d'ailleurs abouti à
la dissolution du parlement et de
nouvelles élections qui ont eu lieu
récemment
vous voilà avec une tasse de café oui
c'était c'était précisément lors du café
c'était au début de l'après midi et je
dois rendre hommage à l'ambassadeur qui
a vraiment fait tout son possible pour
conserver à cette résidence au caractère
particulier ancien et nous sommes
maintenant dans les rues de tokyo
c'est intéressant parce que vous voyez
la proportion des kimonos est vraiment
extrêmement réduite les gens s'habille à
l'européenne là bas la foule est très
dense où avec au milieu au japon il y à
80 millions d'habitants
un kimono voilà un qui mode justement
c'est l'exception qui confirme la règle
et d'un pantalon
c'est ça et les tramways circulent
milieu de la chaussée pas tellement
tellement particulier voyez que la
circulation se fait à gauche ici c'est
un peu particulier les règles de
circulation sont très stricts et peut
qu'on peut dire que japonais dans
l'ensemble les respecte assez d'assez
près de dix ans il est un des rares
agents la police et a cessé vers huy un
des rares agents on envoie c'est assez
peu au japon ce fait cette constatation
petits métiers de la rue tout ça très
classique ça c'est le marchand de
journaux
ça c'est un marchand de tortue tortues
vivantes d'ailleurs qui propose tortues
d'eau oui exactement de selecto qui est
au bord de la mer alors pas étonnant ici
des petits canards qu'on propose quand
les petits métiers de la rue chez les
chaussettes cireuse de chaussures le
masque qu'elle porte est un des aspects
de la deûle à la super hygiène qui est
des caractéristiques du japon je pense
pas qu'il faut aussi développer qu'en
chine actuellement à porter ça c'est le
japon traditionnel s'ils voulaient par
opposition japon moderne
dieu sait si moderne nous arrivons à la
la tour eiffel exactement ça
elle s'appelle la tour général des
ombres électriques et les situer dans un
parent qui s'appelle le parc de shiba
c'est en plein coeur de tokyo et sept
tours aura 330 mètres de haut
il restera légèrement plus haute que la
tour eiffel là-dessus gurat des
émetteurs de radio-télévision servira
aussi pour les ptt pour la gendarmerie
pour les pompiers sont qu'il y aura un
musée scientifique
en somme la construction dans son état
actuel rappelle un petit peu les
superstructures de la tour eiffel il ya
70 ans en iran 88 au moment où l'on
construisait est ce qu'elle sera
illuminée comme la nôtre actuel là ça je
ne sais pas monsieur que c'est probable
en face et dans le domaine de choses
possibles elle sera identique absolument
oui en plus lésés toutefois je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse y mettre à son premier
étage un restaurant et qu'on puisse
faire accéder au dernier étage d'un
ascenseur aussi puissante que ce qui
existe actuellement dans la tour eiffel
de paris et vous voyez qu'on a conservé
les les approches caractéristiques
classiques du japon antique
nous sommes sûrs au marché aux poissons
de tokyo
marché aux poissons qui est extrêmement
animé encore que la période nous y
sommes allés c'est pas tellement la
période de grande pêche ma femme nous
avons tourné ses vues qui sont quand
même caractéristique de ces sept cette
activité de tokyo qui nous sommes dans
la capitale mais aussi un grand port de
pêche pour de commerce et port de pêche
aussi qu il en soit c'est du poisson qui
arrive de
plus large n'est ce pas qui est des
partis pour marquer la dextérité avec
laquelle les ouvriers les pêcheurs manil
les sacs sans pour autant toucher la
matière première
je crois que le poisson et au japonais
ce que le riz et aux chinois elle pas en
français le oui exactement ils en
consomment beaucoup
verrez tout à l'heure nous devons faire
pas la japonaise par exemple un des
trois repas l'année ce que l'on fait là
bas et il était composé exclusivement de
poisson c'est dire que la consommation
est vraiment considérable
alors ce marché aux poissons est
vraiment très très animé des poissons
débarqués d'un poulpe le oui c'est ça
répondu oui le poisson se cède tout de
suite aux enchères à la criée
pratiquement sont appelés ici lors de
lotus égaré dans ses ports alors ça
c'est un défilé sans défilé qui a eu
lieu un samedi je crois que tous les
samedis pratiquement le même rythme se
déroule dans les rues japon de tokyo
exactement ce sont des syndicalistes et
le portent des drapeaux rouges le rouge
étant eux la couleur de base du
syndicalisme au japon et il s'agit d'un
défilé contre la bombe atomique fait que
japon un immense offert de la bombe pour
pouvoir
en parler et ses défilés ont lieu
traditionnellement alors c'est curieux
parce que la police n'intervient pas ne
revient pas au début du moins de ce
qu'on tente de canaliser ce ce cortège à
travers les rues l'espagne a coupé le
cortège qui fait souvent un kilomètre à
le couper en tronçons de 100 150 mètres
6 po facilité quand même la circulation
alors les gens sautent comme ça c'est
une espèce de delon véreux qui qui se
déroule à travers les rues et ces
manifestants vont jusqu'au centre de la
ville où ils savent par expérience et
pas qu'ils n'iront pas plus loin
oui oui à des gens très jeunes sont pour
la plupart des ouvriers ou des étudiants
l'espace tient samedi après midi et les
gens les manifestants scandaient des
slogans ce que des heureux et rejouer le
scander les slogans et chante également
des chansons que je n'ai pas pu on parle
bien entendu
parfois c'était à la fois assez ordonnée
est assez curieux s'espacent très
gentiment en cas de fusion ah oui tout à
fait tout à fait
envoyez-vous ils vont à défaut
d'atteindre le centre de la ville où la
police pratiquement n'aura pas à
intervenir se contentera simplement de
de leur faire comprendre monsieur on ne
va pas plus loin
dispersez vous ça suffit comme ça et
vous allez voir tout à l'heure les
manifestants qui vont revenir sur les
trottoirs là la démonstration est
terminée la manifestation a pris fin et
ça se passe absolument sans orient et
sans heurts avec la police et d'un
auditorium en plein air où tous les
après midi des chanteurs et des
orchestres viennent passer sur les
planches n'est ce pas devant le public
qui entre d'ailleurs gratuitement et qui
donne son avis sur eux sur ces chanteurs
j'allais voir tout à l'heure un andré
claveau japonais qui suit sur une
chanson et vient de chez eux sinon bien
de chez nous avec un désert les plus
populaires au japon c'est la vie en rose
par exemple et que les trois casiers des
reconnaissant persuasif c'est une
fonction japonaise
alors ici un autre aspect de la de la
propreté
oui j'ai remarqué tout est là yb est
liée au marché aux poissons et balayant
car soulier de la foule est susceptible
d'apporter les papiers du baseball avec
le baseball c'est vraiment le sport
national au japon et se dote pas comme
on pourrait le croire de l'occupation
américaine dans le baseball était déjà
le sport numéro 1 au japon avant la
guerre est alors dans tout l'espoir dans
les rues même on voit les hommes
entraîne au baseball absolument comme
chez nous par exemple les jeunes dès
qu'ils ont une minute s'entraîne au
football ici un repas à la japonaise
alors on a un petit peu tricher parce
que il y avait une espèce de rigolant le
sous nos pieds pour mettre nos jambes en
fait on assiste à sir pas ainsi
accroupis n'st pas ici une des chats on
a assuré que sa chevelure était
absolument authentiques qui pose des
problèmes d'ailleurs pour la nuit les
garnir pour garder ce qu elle donne dans
bien je crois la nuque sur une barde
c'était exactement alors ici elle doit
on lui a offert du sac est calé tenu
d'ailleurs de jeter le sac et c'est un
vin de riz qui ce boîtier est d'ailleurs
elle aura pressé et chats qui ont reçu
une éducation extrêmement poussée du
point de vue artistique
on entre dans des écoles du des châles
de 13 ou 14 ans et on y reste en général
jusqu'à 18 ans alors c'est gai chat
exécutant suite des danses et dans ce
sont généralement l'autre de symbole il
est question du folklore japonais d'un
chevalier et sa dame ici cela juste une
danse à l'éventail c'est très gracieux
oui c'est très gracieux leur vous
remarquez la leur visage est so lu ment
de ma sont impassibles
oui absolument c'est ça tout est dans le
mouvement simplement sauf sauf
âge de visage so lu ment impossible
juste les paupières qui bat de temps en
temps ceci en présence de la délégation
française que conduisait vous le
rappelle monsieur monnerville une danse
à l'ombrelle il sourit un peu cette fois
oui oui mais c'est vraiment maximum
c'est à la limite tout ça est très
gracieux il ya assez peu de mouvement
parce qu'elles sont le kimono entrave un
petit peu leur mouvement peut-être est
entravée juge tout à fait elle ressemble
ou au centre de cette guitare ou bruit
assez grêle
ici une autre danse alors une danse
assez assez curieuse parce qu'elle est
exécutée que des masques des masses qui
sont curieux et constraste avec le
visage entassent presque grimaçant dans
ce que vous avez remarqué les les
chaussettes avec un doigt ce qui leur
permettent de chaussée police
alors ça c'est un forme moderne ça c'est
la scène musicale classique ç sud
importations américaines ce que vous
différents la guerre ne connaissez pas
ce spectacle et les jetons et fils ont
mis sur pied un grand capital un
spectacle de music-hall qui sont
d'ailleurs assez suivi lui je connais
ont suivi le mouvement
alors si tokyo la nuit tokyo le quartier
de ginza la petite ginza qui est le
quartier des boîtes de nuit et sur le
quartier vraiment le plus vivante tokyo
dès que la nuit est tombée
alors il ya des illuminés sur vraiment
extraordinaire qui rappelle tout à fait
times square par exemple notamment sais
que vous allez voir tout à l'heure nous
qui représentons ce qu'on voyait pensez
être une corde et qui en fait est une
réclame pour un laxatif
eh bien merci jacques perron vous avoir
ces avis guinée je crois à la semaine
prochaine d'accord